[Music]
Luigi's invited to a gorgeous hotel with
Mario peach and the others oh lucky him
the Luigi's Mansion free this hotel is
much more than meets the guy for not
long after Luigi arrives things take a
dark turn we begin our tour by taking in
some sights and sounds you may never
leave one to leave the other guests
certainly don't plan to move on their
ghosts after all and their rather
aggressive simply scare them with the
strobe of Luigi's new Poltergust g00 has
the powerful suction capabilities
required and are the new features as
well
first the slab trapping of those slam it
on the ground
inflict some damage because to get other
ghosts it on the actual next the suction
shot and finally the plunger to attach
it to something then pulled the string
and you can destroy furniture and
it's effective against certain co-stars
too
[Music]
sometimes ghosts may feel inclined to
hang up on you
in such situations of first trip to the
powerful air pressure with these to blow
away ghosts and it's perfect for when
you need a little air
ah we simply can't overlook the latest
invention from Professor egad namely GUI
G change between Luigi and GUI G to use
both their skills GUI G can do
everything from slipping through metal
fences to walking on spikes indeed there
are obstacles too great for the region
to handle on its own and if you pass a
toy con controller to a friend he makes
for a great co-op partner but proceed
with caution
GUI G and water definitely don't mix now
please direct your attention to the
scare scraper
[Music]
online co-op being would defeat all
ghosts before time runs out
seek and find our deal misplaced toes
and face any challenges the tower throws
at you
[Music]
what a place to wake up in a haunted
hotel with floor after floor of oddities
many traps and mischievous ghosts work
within what will befall our missing
Mario and friends and his dear brother
Luigi
[Music]
[Applause]
Luigi's Mansion 3
[Music]
so that was Luigi's Mansion 3 the latest
game in a series that I personally love
and we can look forward to seeing some
of the new gameplay elements that await
in this strange hotel as we dive deeper
into this title on Nintendo treehouse
live at e3 2019 we'll be streaming
content some you've never seen before
right from the show floor including live
gameplay of Super Mario maker 2 and on
day 3 our treehouse staff will get their
hands on some promising indie games that
are new to Nintendo's switch while you
watch today's Nintendo Direct keep an
eye out for this icon to learn what
other games will appear on Nintendo
treehouse live at e3 2019 you won't want
to miss it